[Music]
the mayor's office hi I'm Jessica Perez
I'm meeting with mayor Wilson and she
said she was sending a car over to pick
me up at the airport can I place you on
a brief hold while I check on this yes
of
course
[Music]
excuse me oh I am so sorry I didn't mean
to hit it I I I it got stuck please all
yours just s clear a d actually I was
actually yes I'm here yes hey right
thank you for your patience I just spoke
with the mayor and your ride should be
there at the Pisa airport
yes well I don't know what to tell you
because I'm standing in the middle of
the only hanger in existence and and
there is no one
else
oh you know thank you for your help I I
I think I found
him are you my ride Matt Holden my
family grows the jingle bell flowers for
the festival mayor Wilson asked me to
make sure that you had everything that
you needed yes good thank you I'm so
sorry about before I I guess I was just
expecting someone you
know with a sign a sign with my name on
it so they can find me at the gate right
wouldn't want to miss you with all these
people here
right are those my cookies oh yeah I
mean I did spring them
free we we can share oh no I I don't
think
so okay well my truck is parked outside
oh
wait
truck